here in Africa a Boomslang is looking
for its favorite meal a chameleon the
Boomslang is one of Africa's longest
tree snakes a perfectly camouflaged
ambush hunter
it has hemo toxic venom small amounts
cause hemorrhaging even death even in
humans
now the chameleon is dangerous to its
own prey of course great eyesight and a
tongue of glue equals lunch the
chameleon has skin that takes on the
colour of its surroundings and eyes that
can spot food or danger in almost any
direction but the chameleon is no match
for the Boomslang the snake sees right
through the chameleons camouflage
but it's still on its own food hunt and
has no idea that it itself is being
hunted an African legend has it that the
gods entrusted the secret of eternal
life to the chameleons as a gift for
mankind but the chameleon was too slow
and death entered our world just as it
enters the chameleons world here the
Boomslang has super-strength venom slow
acting but effective destroying the
vital parts of the victim's blood it has
solid fangs the venom is delivered via
special grooves on the surface the
Boomslang can now enjoy the delights of
its fresh meal
[Music]